-I loved seeing you.
Thanks so much for coming
on the show.
-I'm so happy
when I watch this show
and I'm happy when I'm here.
That John Fogerty thing
was amazing.
-Wasn't that fun?
-It was amazing.
-He was amazing.
He crushed that one.
-You playing the kazoo
like nobody's business.
-Come on.
-I tried the jug and I go,
"I'm going to give up
on the jug."
Yeah, I couldn't really
play that.
-But it was a mini kazoo solo,
so I liked it.
-You heard that?
-I heard that.
-Respect. See?
I love that you pay attention.
You're always great. I know
that you're now living in L.A.,
but I know you're from New York
and your show
was right here in the building.
-That's right.
-When you come back to New York,
does it feel like you're home?
-It feels like I'm home
and I run right to Broadway.
-You do?
-Yeah, I run.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You always have
good recommendations.
What did you see?
-First thing I saw
was Neil Diamond's show
"Beautiful Noise."
-I've not done it yet.
-Now, you know, I thought
it was a jukebox musical.
Just like "Mamma Mia."
A little story.
No, I was sobbing at the end.
It's the story of Neil Diamond
losing his ability
to play on tour
because he has Parkinson's.
And his discussion
with a psychiatrist.
And then Will Swenson.
You know him. He's unbelievable.
Comes out, Tony Award winner,
and he plays Neil Diamond
that we all know.
And then at the end...
-No.
-...they performed together
and mommy was sobbing.
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy, I was a blubbering mess.
-"Oh, no, I'm going to lose it."
I love Neil Diamond.
-Oh, the finale. I don't want to
ruin it for anyone
but the finale --
Go see "Beautiful Noise."
Now, the next thing
you got to go see,
everyone's trying
to get tickets.
"Sweeney Todd."
-I saw that one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, come on!
-The whole cast is amazing.
-Unbelievable.
-Josh Groban.
-Annaleigh.
-Annaleigh Ashford. Oh, my gosh.
-Annaleigh Ashford is
a Tony Award-winning
Lucille Ball
with a voice of a god.
Funny, beautiful, hysterical.
-How funny was she
in this thing?
Made me -- When she fell
down the stairs.
-Fell down the stairs.
-The funniest thing,
The funniest bit.
I am like, "Wow." I was so --
-And you know that
-Is not in the script.
You know, the old lady
falls down the stairs
on her heinie, cracking up
the audience was not
in the script.
-She did that.
-She made that up.
-She does it
and she does it every night.
-Every night.
It was unbelievable.
You have to go see.
And the boy
from "Stranger Things."
-Gaten Matarazzo.
-Oh, my God was he so good.
-Gaten Matarazzo was fantastic.
-Fantastic. What a voice.
-And I've never seen
"Sweeney Todd."
-I knew it.
I saw it with the original.
So it was not funny, though,
in the original.
It's a depressing story.
They're killing people
to make meat pies,
and then they're selling
the meat pies.
-It's a tough sell
if people don't know it.
I go, "It's about a barber
who kills people
and uses the human meat
for meat pies."
And they go, "Okay."
But somehow -- And then you hear
this, like, "Pretty Women."
-Oh, yeah.
-The songs you hear from there,
you go,
♪ No one's going to harm you ♪
♪ Not while I'm around ♪
I go, "That's from
this crazy play?"
-That's from this crazy play.
-It's beautiful.
-But it is so beautiful
and it's so funny.
And I loved every minute of it.
And I think there's going
to be Tonys all around.
But the best thing that I saw
was Sean Hayes
in "Good night, Oscar."
-Really?
-Now, Jimmy...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...this was
an unbelievable performance.
He plays a real guy,
Oscar Levant,
who had a lot of mental problems
and drug problems,
but was a brilliant wordsmith
and one of the intellectual
thinkers of the time.
He went on the Jack Paar show
in the middle
of having a nervous breakdown.
They took him
out of the hospital
for four hours on a leave,
had him perform on "The Tonight
Show" and then leave.
-No.
-And it's a true story.
And Sean Hayes.
-I heard he's amazing.
-Oh, my God, Jimmy,
when he came back to say hello
to all his guests,
I started crying.
You know when you have that cry
that you didn't expect
to cry and you --
I just was like, "Oh, Sean,"
like, I couldn't stop crying.
-Isn't that a weird thing
about Broadway?
I feel so proud of them like
they're my kids or something.
-That's right.
-"I love you, buddy.
You did it. Get over here."
-Yes, "You do it eight times
a week. How do you do it?"
-I had nothing
to do with Sean Hayes at all.
But yes, I'm hugging everybody
at the end like --
-He was -- Jimmy,
it was an extraordinarily
brilliant performance
that I could not believe.
I was witnessing a guy
that I've known and loved
for many years in this role.
I was blown away.
He's going to win every award
and you should get tickets
if you can.
-I love this.
-That's my publicity. Thank you.
Good night. Good night.
-That's all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But I love -- You're like --
Yeah, I go,
"I'll talk about your podcast."
You go, "Jimmy, I don't need to
talk about it."
-Yeah, whatever.
Yeah, I have a podcast
wherever podcasts are sold.
"Rosie O'Donnell Onward."
-Yeah. There you go.
-Go. Okay.
-But you are no stranger
to Broadway not only supporting
but you actually --
I've seen you perform in --
Was it "Grease"?
-I was in "Grease."
You want to guess who I played?
-Yeah. Rizzo.
-Yeah. It wasn't Sandy.
Sometimes people ask me --
[ Laughter ]
People go, "You were in
'Grease.' Who did you play?"
And I just wait a second.
And then I say, "Danny Zuko."
[ Laughter ]
-But you always say, you go,
"I can't really sing."
You can sing.
-Listen, I'm not a singer
like the singers
you see on Broadway.
And I grew up loving
Barbra Streisand.
And if that's the one
that you're going to hold high
as the highest voice you've ever
heard, you're nowhere near that.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, exactly.
-So I know I can sing
funny patter songs
and I know I can
do the comedy involved,
but it's not like
they're putting on a new musical
and they go, "You know,
can we get that Rosie O'Donnell?
Because that voice
is so soothing."
-People really -- No, yeah.
But you crushed it there.
And you know what
you're also crushing is TikTok.
Yes.
-TikTok loves you.
-I love TikTok.
You don't stop, right?
-TikTok. You don't stop.
-Exactly.
-But how did you
get involved with TikTok?
-My daughter,
who's 20 years old
and was very bored
during the pandemic.
And her name is Vivi.
She's very beautiful,
very smart.
And she told me
that I had to do one with her.
And I'm like,
"I'm not going to dance.
It's going to look ridiculous."
And so I did it just
because I'm a mom.
-You'd do anything
for your kids.
-But you do anything to make
her happy for five minutes.
And then this kid
who was like a 20-year-old kid,
copied it and made fun of me.
And then I went on
and made fun of him.
And then it became
like a thing, you know?
And I'm like, "You mean I can,
like, have fun
and play with strangers
on this thing?"
I think it's the best
invention in a long time.
I hope they don't ban it because
I really enjoy my TikTok.
-Yeah, no, I hope
they don't ban it either.
-Yeah.
-You're good at it.
-You can connect people to
people, you know,
And I -- My daughter has autism
and she's 10 years old.
And I connect with
so many autism moms.
And, you know,
when you have a niche like that
and you want to talk to someone
who really understands,
I've met people
and have real relationships
that serve my life
through doing that.
And sometimes
when you're famous,
you don't get to meet
new people anymore.
You know, because people think
that you're different than them,
even though you're just
the same kid
that grew up on Long Island
and took the train
in to see "Pippin."
You know, for the second act,
and I would hide and
the ushers wouldn't find me,
and then I'd run and watch
Jill Clayburgh on stage
and John Rubenstein.
-This way you can
connect to people and you go,
"Yeah, I was that person."
-Exactly.
And people, you know, on TikTok,
they don't seem so impressed
with your celebrity at all.
You know, they're kind of like,
"Oh, hi, Rosie,
What are you doing on tonight?"
I'm like, "Yeah, frankly,
I'm watching that
'Horrible Love is Blind.'"
[ Laughter ]
The worst show on TV,
ever been on television.
-That's so funny.
-I'm going to hide in a booth
and only listen to you
for six weeks,
and then I'm going to move in
with you for two months,
and then we're going
to see if it lasts.
Good luck, kiddies.
-Sounds like something
I would watch. Yeah.
-Yeah. I don't recommend.
-I think they can --
Also, if you are successful
on the social media,
it's because you're honest.
I think people
can smell a phony.
-It's so true.
-They can sniff it out and they
go, "Oh, this is someone else.
This is someone else
doing it for you.
You're not being yourself.
You're not being real."
-Right? And we've had
so much in our society
and our culture with lies
and with misinformation
and with fakeness
and what's real and what's not.
And what do the Kardashians
look like before the surgeon?
[ Laughter ]
You know?
Don't forget, honey.
Don't forget. That's all tricky,
Pretend nothing, right?
Don't strive for that.
You know, you have to strive
for something real.
And I think in our society
with art now,
with music, with our culture,
people want authenticity.
They want to be told the truth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
By you.
-Yeah. Real.
-That's all that matters, right?
-That's why we love you.
I do want to talk
about your podcast,
"Onward with Rosie O'Donnell."
It's basically
you were telling me
it's just you chatting
with friends.
-Pretty much. You know, I turned
60 and I went,
"Listen, what do I want to do?"
-Happy birthday.
-Thank you.
-If I'm lucky, I'm actually 61
now, but when I turned 60 --
-Happy belated 60th.
-Thank you. When I turned 60, I
went, "You know what?
I'm going to rent myself a place
on the beach for one year.
I'm going to get a chef
to cook me healthy food.
I'm going to lose some weight.
I'm going to feel better
about my life
and I'm going to decide what do
I want to do
with the last 30 summers
should I be lucky enough
to live to 90.
What do I want to do?"
Right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
And so that's why the podcast
seemed like a wonderful thing,
because I get to be home
with my kid and raise her
and I get to talk to friends
and still be a part
of the pop culture,
but not so much in that it takes
over your world, you know?
-Good.
-That's what aging does.
You don't give a crap anymore,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-I want to -- We're going
to go to commercial,
but I just want to tell you that
when I started "Late Night,"
I don't know if you remember
this, but you gave me
such great advice.
You were so nice to me.
You said
what's it like and what are you
doing for the audience
and how are you going to warm
up, down to the last detail.
And I remember I was at
an event, like a charity event,
and you were sitting next to me
and you go, "Jimmy,
how's the 'Late Night'
thing going?
You working hard?"
I go, "I am, Rosie."
I'm writing, I'm working hard.
I really want this to win."
You go,
"Are you doing test shows?"
I go, "I am."
And a test show doesn't air.
And so you kind of ask
your friends or your neighbors
just "can you come
on a fake talk show
and have me interview?"
And I go, "I'm doing tests."
And you go,
"I want to be on it."
-Yeah.
-And you came on our test show
and I'll never, ever forget it.
-Yeah.
-It was awesome.
-And you were great.
And I'm so proud of you.
I really am.
You're a wonderful man.
-Rosie O'Donnell.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-"Onward" wherever podcasts --
-Anywhere. Anywhere.
-Anywhere!
IHeart Radio app, wherever.
We'll be right about with Suga,
everybody.
Come on, stick around.